welcome back to age 20 special
relativity
in this section we want to build on we
just learned about the relativistic
doppler effect and redshift
so we take on traveling through the
galaxy from here from earth towards the
center of the galaxy the situation is as
follows we have bob who's stationary on
our planet earth
and alice who's makes use of a new space
bar that spacecraft is able to travel
with a velocity of
0.99999998 times the speed of light so
that's really fast corresponds to a
gamma factor of 15
now the center of the galaxy is about 30
000 light years away
and in bob's reference frame this
journey will take about 30 000 years
because the velocity is about the speed
of light
for alice however the journey will only
take two years so that's quite doable
the question now is what does lsc
literally what is she going to see while
she is looking out of the windows of the
spacecraft this is a picture
similar to the one we see in in some of
the movies where
you know
there's on the horizon there's lots of
stars and once the space spacecraft
accelerates you see those dots kind of
blurry coming towards us stripes
or is the situation somehow different
the starlight has a wavelength of about
600 nanometers
and the cosmic microwave background
wavelength of 1.06 millimeters
so how is ellis going to observe those
two light sources
in her trouble
so i invite you to work this out but
also think about the next question how
long does it take for alice to
accelerate from zero to her velocity
with an acceleration of 10 meters per
second squared which is one g which is
very very doable for her
okay so i invite you to stop the video
here and work out those numbers to get a
feel and speculate a little bit about
how this journey is actually going to
look like
so here's the solution
so
the is moving towards us so it's going
to be blue shifted
the velocity
is given here
is better
we have seen that redshift or oneplus
redshift is equal to the emitted
wavelength provided by the observed
wavelength
and you find that that factor is ten
thousand
so we just have to divide
our emitted wavelength by ten thousand
and find that the observed starlight has
a wavelength of 4.6 0.06
nanometers which is x-ray
so she's going to be flooded by x-ray as
lights coming from these stars
and similarly the observed cosmic
microwave background is going to be
about 106 nanometers this which is
ultraviolet light
so the ultraviolet light there's a
spectrum to this so what she's going to
see
is
x-ray which you can actually not see
with her eyes but she will be able to
see the ultraviolet or some part of the
spectrum as a kind of a blurry fuzzy
kind of background
all over the place
so the situation is actually different
from
what we just saw in this picture
a few more fun facts about the cosmic
microwave background
it's actually at a temperature so
um the spectrum of cosmic microwave
backgrounds those protons they
correspond to a spectrum emitted by
this which corresponds to a specific
temperature of 2.7 kelvin
that is
the temperature of our universe
this temperature was about 3000 kelvin
about 380 000 years after the big bang
the age of the universe at the time
and then at that time this corresponds
to visible light
but at that moment
the light stopped interacting or stopped
um
the likelihood for the light to interact
with something outside in the universe
became so low that it just stopped
interacting and then the frequency uh
changed because the universe was
expanding
so what we are seeing today is kind of a
relic of the universe
at that time at three hundred eighty
thousand years after the big bang
and if you study the my prosthetic
microwave background with some more
precision you see that there's actually
a fluctuation which can be analyzed
it turns out that you can collide
correlate those fluctuations
fluctuations of the energy density 800
380 000 years after big big bang this
the presence of today's stars and
galaxies and galaxy clusters
so those energy fluctuations are served
as seeds
for the formation of galaxies and galaxy
transplants
quite interesting
today we have about 400 of those photons
microwave photons
per square cubic centimeters that's
quite
busy environment around you know this
little cube has about 400 what's not
supported
but this is a spectrum as well but it's
not just a monochromatic
[Music]
background but it's a spectrum which
corresponds to this temperature
all right
you